qui ne l'a jamais porté le cas où un
incontournable de l'enfance qui malgré
son nom est bien né en france dans le
pas-de-calais précisément en 1965 une
idée de léon claude duhamel au détour
d'une terrasse parisienne attend
d'ailleurs passé d'une jeune maman avec
deux petits enfants qui avaient des
vêtements rouges
manifestement en nylon non doublet que
j'ai l'idée de faire un produit du même
genre mais thad alled à l'origine ne
produisait pas du tout destiné à être
imperméable et pas du tout destiné à
être enduit un vêtement imperméable
d'abord baptisé en k2 comprenait en cas
de pluie un nom bien français trop
français surtout pour s'exporter à
l'international
c'est la vente du site et préférer un
non américain et notamment beaucoup de
noms qui se terminait par ou et parce
que vous êtes à quelque chose qui sonne
bien en toutes les langues
finalement après beaucoup de semaines de
réflexion c'est mon père qui lui était
proposé de prendre le k2 en cas est loué
pour faire car web
une bonne idée qui ne tardera pas à
porter ses fruits
quelques deux cent cinquante mille
exemplaires vendus dès la première année
de lancement une collaboration avec
l'équipe de france de ski alpin dans les
années 70 et surtout un nom qui tombe
dans le langage courant le début aussi
des premières contrefaçons
si tous les produits cao et ils sont
appelés chaos exempt sur le marché
étaient des bons produits
ce serait pas grave à la limite mais
malheureusement surtout en coupe vent il
ya beaucoup de produits de très mauvaise
qualité mais après 25 ans d'un succès
grandissant la décennie 90 sera plus
difficile pour l'entreprise concurrence
asiatique licenciement l'équilibré
financier est fragilisée en 1999
lusine d'arn dans le nord de la france
là où tout a commencé
fermer définitivement ses portes elle
n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle-même 400
personnes et travailler il ya vingt ans
46 aujourd'hui ils attendent leur lettre
de licenciement
k way harnes c'est fini il faudra
attendre 2004 pour voir k-way renaître
de ses cendres
la marque est alors racheté par un
groupe italien
et dix ans plus tard l'entreprise opère
un retour aux sources dans lé nord de la
france la marque du fameux couvent de
poche rouvre une boutique à lille créé à
roubaix dans les années 60 anti
transpirant et plus faciles à enfiler
nous promettons il est monté en gamme
avec des prix allant cette fois de 49 à
300 euros pour les modèles les plus
chics 53 ans après sa création le kawa
s'est définitivement imposé comme un
accessoire de mode incontournable
[Musique]